[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم في حوار
اليوم هو وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيه شكرا
جزيلا لوجودكم معنا شكرا على دعوتكم قال
الرئيس
انه يعتقد بان اوكرانيا بامكانها الاتصال
في هذه الحرب في 2023 وسمعنا الى اعلى
جنرال امريكي الذي اعرب ان تشكوكاته ورئيس
الفرنسي والمستشار الالماني قال بان هذه
الحرب ستكون طويله الامل وهل تؤمنون بانكم
ستنتصرون بشكل حاسم هذه السنه ان لم نكن
مؤمنين بالانتصار في هذه الحرب ما كنا
لنستمر في القتال
اريد وضع حد لهذه الحرب اكثر من اي بلد في
العالم هذا هو هدفنا بطبيعه الحال ونحن
نحاول تعبئه كل مواردنا لتحقيق ذلك نقل
رئيسه بانه يريد المواصله يبدو ان
استراتيجته تخص حرب المتعثر يريد استنزاف
مقاومه اوكرانيا وان يستنفذ اسلحتها
ودخائرها وهناك بعض الدوائر الغربيه التي
تعرب عن مشاغلها وتعتقد بان موجه تنقلب ضد
اوكرانيا في صحه المهارات اعتقد بان هذه
الاوصات تشعر بالقلق اذاء نفسها ليس هناك
اي هروب لرياح معاكسه لان اوكرانيا تقاتل
من اجل قضيه عادله اي بمعنى اخر اوكرانيا
تحارب ضد حق القويه في الاعتداء على
الضعيف وضد حق القوي على فرض ارادته على
جيرانه الذي يعتقد بانهم اضعف منه اننا
ندافع عن القانون الدولي عن ميثاق الامم
المتحده والحق في هذا الى جانبنا
كل من يؤمن بالحق والحقيقه واحترام لسياده
وسلامه اراضي الدول عليه ان يقف الى
جانبنا
وجميله انتم بالتاكيد بحاجه الى عقوبات
وام واهم ذلك الى اسلحه هناك اتفاق بارسال
دبابات الى اوكرانيا لكن ما بين الاتفاق
والواقع ماذا يحصل الى اي مرحله وصلنا
بالنسبه لهذه المساله الاساسيه لاوكرانيا
نحن بحاجه الى الاسلحه والعقوبات والاموال
والتضامن وكل بلد من بلدان العالم يستطيع
ان يجد افضل مكانه له لتلبيه احتياجاتنا
في هذه المجالات الاربعه مثال ان كانت
هناك دوله من دول الجنوب لا تريد ارسال
اسلحه في بامكانها التعبير عن التضامن
السياسي مع اوكرانيا مع الدفاع عن المبادئ
وعبر التصويت على مقررات الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده ذات الصله بامكان بعض دول
اخر تقديم الاسلحه البعض الاخر تقديم
المال ودول اخرى فرض العقوبات اذا هناك
طرق كثيره لدعم اوكرانيا
نعم هو موجود حيث هناك بعض الدورات
التدريبيه في هذا المجال بعض الدول تقدم
لمشاكل قطع الغيار الدبابات التي يودون
ارسالها الى اوكرانيا ليس لدي ادنى شك بان
هذه العمليه تسير في المسار الصحيح ولكن
الامر يتعلق فقط بالوقت والمدد اسابيع
اشهر تقول اسابيع ما الامر بالنسبه
لطائرات المقاتله هذا الامر لم يتم
الاتفاق بشانه هل تعتقد بانهم من الصواب
السباق الاحداث
هذا مشروع طويل الاجل ولكن ليس باجل طويل
جدا لا ينبغي الحديث عن الطائرات في
الواقع بصوره منعزله لذلك هنا نحن نتحدث
عن المنصات وليست طائرات فقط فالطائرات هي
جزء مهم من نظام الدفاع الجوي من اجل
اسقاط الصواريخ الروسيه التي تستهدف البنى
التحتيه
الحساسه في مجال الطاقه وتقوم بقتل
المدنيين
فيما يتعلق بالطائرات الحربيه فان
الاستراتيجيه مختلفه مقارنه بالاسلحه
الاخرى عندما نتحدث عن انواع الاسلحه
الاخرى والعمليه تكون على الشكل التالي
يتم اولا الاعلان عن تقديم هذه الاسلحه ثم
يتم تنظيم دورات تدريبيه للجنود
الاوكرانيين على استخدامها اما في حاله
الطائرات قمنا بقلب الاليه حيث يتم اولا
تدريب توقم الطيارين بانتظار القرار
النهائي بشان تسليم الطائرات هل هذا يعني
بانك تفكر في اف 16 او ميكس التي يمكن
ربما ان تسلم الى اوكرانيا
لا ارى اي معارضه في وصف حقوقيه مكان اخر
الامر يتعلق بعمليه الانتخاب القرارات
لم تتخذ بعد
سيتم اتخاذ القرارات
في السنه الماضيه قلنا نحن بحاجه الى سبعه
انواع من الاسلحه من اجل وقف الاعتداء
والعدوان
وطردهم من اوكرانيا في 12 شهرا نحن حصلنا
على سته انواع من هذه الاسلحه ونحن
اسميناها بالاسلحه السبع الكبرى
وفي كل سلاح وكل نوع هذه الانواع كانت
الاجابه بشانها اولا لا وبعد ذلك اصبحت
هذه الاجابه نعم واعتقد هو نفس الشيء
سينسحب على هذا الامر قلت انه ما دام
ابوتين بالكرملين ستكون اوكرانيا في ورطه
هذا يتطلب بوضوح التغيير النظام
بغيه ارساء السلام باوكرانيا
ليس فقط اوكرانيا في ازمه لننظر الى ما
يحدث في البلقان وجمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى
وحيث هناك مجموعه فادني التي تخلع الكثير
من الضغط والمشاكل بشان استقرار البلدان
الجاره لننظر الى سوريا
انحاء العالم نرى استراتيجيه بوتين التي
تستهدف الدمار
وبالتالي هو يركز على اذاعه الاستقرار
الفرصه الوحيده لبوتين ان يحصل على شيء ما
يتمثل بنشر عدم الاستقرار
عمله هي ليست هو ليس فقط مشكله اوكرانيه
بل هو مشكله عالميه وايضا بالنسبه لبلدان
الجنوب وبلدان الشمالي ايضا
وبالتالي لا يمكن ان يكون هناك عضو دائم
لمجلس الامن الدولي
مع سلاح نووي ينشر الفوضى في جميع انحاء
العالم اذا طالما بقي هناك ستبقى المشكله
قائمه على العالم ان يتخلص منه لان بعض
القاده في الغرب رئيس الفرنسي يقولان بانه
علينا ان الناس حق روسيا
مواصله الحديث معهم هل هذا خطا لم اعد
اسمع مساله عدم اذلال واهانه بوتين منذ
عده اشهر هذه السرديه نعم كانت موجوده قبل
ذلك الهجوم الموسعه ضد اوكرانيا وهذه
سرديه فاشله
الشعب الروسي وحده
يقرر من يقود روسيا
كيفيه افهام الروس بان بوتين هي يمثل ايضا
مشكله بالنسبه لهم
ما الامر بالنسبه للصين التي قالت بانها
تريد القيامه بالوساطه بشان خطه سلام
وسمعنا ايضا الى الولايات المتحده التي
حضرت الصين من اعطاء روسيا امدادات فتاتها
بالنسبه لهاتين المسالتين الحال ينظر
الجميع الى الصين كقوه عالميه ونحن نتطلع
الى
هذه المقترحات مقترحات السلام التي تحدث
عنها السيد وانجي وزير الخارجيه الصيني
نعم نحن التقيناه في ميونخ وكان هناك نقاش
ونحن بعد الاطلاع على هذه الخطه
سنستخلص العبر
الخطوط الحمراء المشتركه مع الصين تتمثل
بالاحترام الصارم لسلامه الاراضي سلامه
اراضي الدول واذا قام احد
العالم ليس فقط بالنسبه للصين اذا قام اي
بلد من بلدان العالم بارسال اسلحه الى
روسيا هذا يعني بان هذا البلد يساعد روسيا
على انتهاك سلامه الاراضي هل لديك بعض
الدلائل بكون هذا ما تفعله هنا اتحدث عن
اي بلد من البلدان العالم من شان ان تقوم
بذلك هذا يعني بان هذا البلد يعمل وينتهك
سلامه الاراضي والمبادئ هذه المشكله مهمه
ان اوكرانيا تمارس حق الدفاع المشروع عن
النفس هذا المشروع النصوص عليه في ميثاق
الامم المتحده بالتالي فان ارسال الاسلحه
الى بلد يدافع عن نفسه امر مشروع من اجل
دفاع هذا البعد عن نفسه ولكن ارسال هذه
الاسلحه الى المعتدي هذا الامر يجعلك
متواطئا ومذنبا في جريمه العدوان اشارتها
الى ارسال الاسلحه الرئيس البرازيلي لولا
قال بانه لن يرسل الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا
هناك مشكله
منها الحلفاء الغربيون اي اقناع البلدان
في امريكا اللاتينيه وافريقيا واسيا
بمساعدتكم لاحظنا ذلك في الامم المتحده
اعتقد بانكم ستذهبون هناك من اجل تصويت
جديد لماذا لا تستطيعون اقناعهم اكثر
نعم هذا سؤال وجيه
اعتقد بان الجواب الصحيح
يتمثل بانه هناك شريحه واسعه من الطرق
بشان التعبير عن نفس ازاء الاعتداء
الروسيه على اوكرانيا ان لم تستطع دوله من
دول ارسال اسلحه يمكن تقديم الدعم السياسي
عبر التعبير عن التضامن في محافل مختلفه
كالامم المتحده على سبيل المثال ويمكن هذا
لهذا البلد ان يمتنع عن دعم روسيا على
الالتفاف على العقوبات هناك اشياء اخرى
يمكن القيام بها طالما لا بعد هذه الدوله
روسيا هناك دائما طرق لمساعده اوكرانيا
لماذا تفعل ذلك بعض البلدان اعتقد هنا بان
بعض الدول تم تضليلها بشان صوره روسيا
وبسبب صوره روسيا
بعض البلدان لديها علاقه تاريخيه مع روسيا
البعض الاخر يريد البقاء على صداقه مع
روسيا ومع اوكرانيا في نفس الوقت وهذا امر
صعب جدا في الظروف الحاليه نحن نحترم هنا
جميع الاراء الموجوده في العالم لانها دول
ذات سياده ولكن راينا واضح نحن ندافع عن
انفسنا ومن
المشروعيه
ان يتم دعمنا والروس يعتدوا علينا ومن غير
المشروع دعم روسيا هلا تامل الحصول على
اصوات اكثر لصالح اوكرانيا في الامم
المتحده حيث الجمعيه العامه ستصوت هذا
الاسبوع
نحن نعمل على هذا الموضوع هذا يندرج في
اطار الدبلوماسي التقليدي للحصول على اكبر
عدد من الاصوات في الجمعيه العامه لو
المتحده نحن نركز على وجه التحديد على
بلدان الجنوب التي نحن نحترمها ونحن نريد
من هذه البلدان البلدان الجنوب ان تعبر عن
تضامنها مع اوكرانيا ونحن نقترب من الذكرى
السنويه الاولى للغزو الشامل ولكن هذه
المناسبه تتزامن ايضا مع الذكرى السنويه
التاسعه للاعتداء الروسيه على اوكرانيا في
شهر فبراير 2014 عندما استولت على القرم
وهذا شكل انتهاكا لجميع قوانين الشرعيه
الدوليه وبالتالي الخيار يتمثل بالدفاع عن
القانون الدولي عبر الوقوف الى جانب
اوكرانيا مثل كوليباس شكرا جزيلا على
حضوركم معنا في حوار
شكرا لكم جميعا على المتابعه